[Music]
what we are doing in our lab right now
is I think for the first time truly the
first steps towards building cybernetic
systems cyborgs you know we've been
reading about this in our science
fiction for years and it's finally
starting to get there my entire life I
never thought that I would be where I am
now having had an amputation I have an
opportunity to engineer my own body and
I had always dreamed about that the
implications of making a seamless
connection between the body and the
robot means that we en disability
[Music]
my name is Everett Lawson I'm a research
assistant at MIT in the Media Lab I
don't know that I would necessarily call
myself an inventor but I like to make
things and I like to make things that
allow me to see and feel and experience
things that I would have not otherwise
been able to
[Music]
I was born with a congenital clubfoot
and what it really came down to is that
the bones were weaker so even just
stepping off of a curb I could break my
foot I remember once I was running from
a bear on a dirt road and I stepped on a
rock and I broke my foot a few years ago
my wife and I found out that we were
going to have our son August and I had
reconstructive surgery to allow me to
run around and chase my son and pick him
up after he was born
[Music]
and after having that surgery I didn't
heal my leg was just absolutely
deteriorating and the surgeon said well
we think that an amputation is going to
be the best outcome for you and I was
sitting in my office
dumbstruck and a great mentor of mine
happened to come to my office and saw me
sitting there and he literally grabbed
me by the arm and he said that's it and
he took me and he marched me downstairs
across the lab down into hue hers lab my
name is Hieu her I'm the professor at
MIT and I direct a research group called
the biomechatronics group we develop
wearable robots robots that attach to
the body mechanically and neroli
we met with Everett that day and
determined that ever it would benefit
from receiving the Ewing amputation this
experimental surgery which is a truly
unique approach to performing an
amputation in a traditional amputation
and not only are they cutting through
the bone but they're also cutting
through all the muscles and tendons as
well in the Ewing procedure they
preserve as much of that musculature as
they can and the relationship of those
muscles be of attendance I still have
the musculature embedded into my limb
which means that I can have a direct
neuromuscular interface with bionic
limbs and that's how I started this
relationship with the biomechatronics
lab
[Music]
my name is Matt Carney I'm a PhD
candidate here in the biomechatronics
group and I have been building Bionic
knees and ankles trying to push the
limits of what's actually possible to
get as close as possible or even better
than biological performance what's
really interesting about everett is that
because he's had this amputation it
allows him to have this neural pathway
that a traditional amputation doesn't
necessarily have so that he can have
direct control of the robot how it works
is that there are sensors that read the
signals coming out of the muscles in my
leg and it translates them into
mechanical motion within the bionic limb
so when I fire a muscle that would say
point your foot down it directly
translates to a motion in the robotic
vehicle I think
[Music]
a range of motion for the dorsiflexion
feels really good it does yeah I
remember the first time that I you know
saw of Matt's robotic engine and he
turned on the controls I wasn't seeing
the mechanics of this robot attached to
my body I was seeing my body being
continued all the way down to a foot
that had a 1:1 relationship between the
thought of motion and actual motion
it was truly profound so you can put it
on we'll try it out we'll turn it up a
little bit I need a little bit more
resistance on hill strick well yes
Mord anthony freakin strike how does it
feel I just made it that's way better
quite a bit stiffer yeah
working with Matt and the team in the
position of being a subject it is a
really interesting situation for me but
I also am an engineer and an inventor
and you know I also work on developing
my own systems and rather than trying to
translate my thoughts into motion I'm
looking at how do I get sensory feedback
back in
so I received this experimental surgery
which preserved a lot of the musculature
of my leg as well as portions of the
nervous system and I began to realize
that there was specific spots on my leg
that have an approximate sensation of
the big toe the little toe the heel the
middle of my foot and it was at that
point that I started prototyping
building things in order to start
exploring these sensations within the
last 48 hours I've been able to build an
array of sensors they go on to the
bottom of my prosthetic they'd send a
signal back on to my residual limb a
little bit of electricity across the
surface of the skin to get the sensation
of touch so I can reach down and I can
touch this one and I have the sensation
of my little toe I'll guess do you know
it could help Papa do you want to help
me do science you want to tickle the
bottom of Papa's robot foot pop off the
bottom all the way on the bottom I'll
push that one oh I feel that can you
push other buttons you touching my pinky
toe and my big toe and it actually
really tickles I hadn't thought some of
this all the way through oh that's no
sir that's live wires
August is born with bilateral cleft feet
the condition that I had but on both
sides you know the science has changed a
lot and they're able to do treatments to
correct it but sitting there as a father
you know looking at my son my motivation
for building bionic limbs came from
thinking about the world that have won
him to grow up in
you know I think it's 2019 and it's
about time we got robots on people one
hope coming out of this lab is that the
work we were doing allows us to push the
capabilities of what the human body is
even capable of doing so that at some
point you know it's not just I feel so
bad that you lost your limb here's some
prosthesis it's more like oh I lost my
limb cool look what I can do now I can
upgrade that limb as I get older I can
change all the functionality of it I
have so much more capability now that I
have this new robotic extension of my
body
the things that we're developing now the
prototype that I'm wearing today is just
the beginning
[Music]
I don't think it's ever going to stop
it's not about building something that
does X and I can just move on from there
it's going to be a constant exploration
throughout the course of my life
you